okay four people joining this live
stream we're in the late stages of
documentation for what's going into
version 12 for synthetic geometry I do
want to raise the issue of the coloring
of let's see if we go to adjustments
what what do you think you're gonna do
for that little bit small circles a
little bit smaller fun a small change in
the blue to it to a little bit more cave
what about Jeremy which you stole from
us okay do you have a mock-up you could
show me no okay all right I just think
the main problem is you know ultimately
we want to do cartographic style
labeling what we put those things where
they won't interfere with anything else
um but the issue is right now I mean
these are beautiful but rather know
obstructive right Michael actually
implemented the smaller point and font
sizes locally already although I haven't
changed the blueness and some colorblind
I mean another point that I asked
yesterday evening is do we consider what
we now call diatoms in geometry to be
more like plots meaning that the front
sides of a label is absolute or to be
considered a more like a molecule that
the font size is relative I don't know
what do you think I think the arguments
for both sides well I was thinking of
some compromise position where they get
bigger up to some point yeah we
discussed this we do not really have
decent technology to hear less this okay
absent that I think we have to do
absolute size but yeah when the points
are kind of wish together a little bit
you need to be able to stretch out this
picture without the the points getting
bigger too
I mean opium is of course a little bit
amplified in the documentation because
the documentation between lose sight for
cafe that's a little bit smaller than
did you fall in a notebook right
you come abroad beyond red green like
this blue isn't visible well it's it's
how I it's invisible but if you don't
think you have a same impression that
other people have of it
right blue and purple kind of mix
together for me Oh makes sense yeah
interesting boy how do we do in general
with our coloring given your
colorblindness does the coloring do we
do we mess it up completely I mean we
have thought about that issue I mean
it's like for some tax coloring and
things like that usually most of the
syntax coloring I'm okay with there are
a few cases where deeper down sometimes
let's get a little confusing for me but
like the kind of the top level stuff if
it's a if it's a scoping contract I can
tell those apart from I'm not sure
anybody else is any less confused okay
alright let's continue I mean I do like
the colorfulness of this blue so don't
don't let's have the whole thing sort of
gray and turn into mud so to speak
there's one other point which wasn't
fully implemented yet current emphasizes
color we use for the connect Rose is the
blue but Jeremy wanted a porch which I
luckily I just changed it to orange it
looks good I mean I could as far as I
know about what orange will that's funny
that's a funny situation okay um the
okay
um alright let's keep going here okay so
let's start off with triangle Center
which I hope and believe will be fairly
straightforward up to ten to eight
hundred is easy to up to what choking
because there are fifteen thousand
temples that to be use yeah just think
how many it will be for Pentagon's why
aren't there many centers for squares
because it's totally obvious what the
center I mean for quadrilaterals there
must be many centers as well there's
nobody care about those I think a lot of
the triangle centers are I think it I
think it kind of has to do with you know
three points determinate a circle
I think four quadrilaterals
once you add points I think I think the
existence of these centers becomes much
more difficult
I see long center types come to used ok
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute you should list don't you want to
list these so the case where the thing
has a point
in all of those cases they're given as a
list of above no no I realized that I
realized that I'm asking whether that's
the right thing well this one here
somebody an endpoint oh I see some idiom
point yeah hmm I see there's no
ambiguity no it's wrong majority it's a
question whether it's clear what's going
on I mean because people
you know what we could do is we could
list the ones that are independent of
any point first in one table and then go
on and list the ones that require point
or is that a waste of time
I don't necessarily think that's a bad
idea especially for triangle Center in
the sense that you know the ones that
don't require point are kind of more of
a center than the ones that do require
point okay all right okay the following
Center types following basic Center
types can be used okay so here then
we've got um centroid yeah this is a
nice list circumcenter I know what an
Exeter point is we don't have it was
we're not gonna probably have it anytime
soon yeah I mean these are all centers
that I've heard of well except the
Cimmerian which we talked about lost
some times ago which I hadn't heard out
but okay
the following Center types along Center
types oh um do we want is to
differentiate between the center types
that whose additional argument is one of
the points of the triangles and the
center types is additional argument is
at any point in general of course at
once no let's do the ones well these are
all vertex P right see mine endpoint
takes both a center point and a vertex P
right and I look well let's let's treat
that one so yeah what's the net what's
the other one I said there might not be
another one let me look
yes deceiving and point on a vertex
depending on specifying of vertex oh
yeah just sieving and yes even in points
the only one that can have a another
point in general doesn't have to be a
vertex of the track of an utterly
irrelevant question from the live stream
but I'll answer it the answer is we're
hoping so it's a question of high DPI
support on Windows and twelve point oh
we're hoping so um okay following center
types depend on specifying am a vertex
and then we're going to say let's let's
give the table and then we'll say um
well let's see the
Center types to balance by swelling and
by default by default taking the the
point p2 in the specification of the
triangle okay um okay now here's my idea
okay so first of all let's clean it down
to that list
does that one always have to have a
center let C be an endpoint no I think
by default it takes the other sin
charger orthocenter centroid okay oops
okay now what I'm gonna do here is okay
here we go
hydro type comma P use vertex P now what
can P be what what is what what is P is
P an index or is P no that's a point
good are the vertices
alright but what is it when it's a
literal triangle Center
you get what I'm asking what when it's
not a symbolic triangle center then you
give an explicit point you mean as a as
a point of seven point two six feet
right okay we could have it work for
indices and in fact an may already have
that implemented but II
think about how to document that I
totally forget whether I implemented it
for that but hold on hold on let's so
we'll just say at the vertex endpoint
Assyrian bisecting the angle at the
vertex and then we remove that okay is
this really the best thing to call it
foot as opposed to altitude foot and
whether chair raised opposite the vertex
why opposite from the vertex okay okay
this is what I suggest okay and then we
have to say then we say okay
Cillian endpoint right I think in has
paragraph on that too below I see it
oh gosh you've got a way of doing it for
all of them
that's super confusing is that what you
want for this here I don't do it for
every one of them if you can do it face
it does it does work for all of them I
mean okay okay okay okay okay all works
for each of them yeah I understand so
now we want to say type comma all give a
list of results for all vertices of the
triangle is that right that is correct
okay see be an endpoint of um sort of
use point P I think it should be used
vertex P I just can't just be in a point
okay but then then then in that case can
it be an index or does it have to be in
the form I figure out whether I allow
embassies let me check okay P can be
coordinates XY
point XY the index I for okay well Matt
can be a symbolic point specification in
a geometric scene or can be explicit an
explicit vertex in the form XY point XY
or index I of the vertex is that right
yeah it does look like I'm supporting
index I'm not sure if I'm currently
supporting point but I can make that
happen pretty easily okay okay okay
type comma P gives the through the
vertex P and the center of a specified
type it doesn't have to be a type that
can also be a an actual point like two
comma three okay the center can be given
as a center type or by explicit or as an
or or as a point specification is that
right that's great hey all right please
what's that
you
okay okay it's not always equivalent
when is it equivalent triangle construct
takes more types than triangle Center
does which is why I don't think we
should put it in here I don't think we
should put it here it's not really
relevant okay oh this is just
unbelievably way too complicated come on
just say you know find the center of a
triangle find the in centre of a
triangle we forget all this what are you
doing here I'm sorry I'm sorry
look this should start off just find the
in center of a triangle and just do it
right and preferably do one which has
nice square roots and all kinds of
things like that you know I don't know
whether whether this is you know just do
the thing two dots do you know but I
don't you shouldn't define variables or
anything like that you really really
shouldn't and you shouldn't ever do this
of doing never do this that's not even
like do you it's like if you want to
proof that this really decays and then
you don't want to repeat it around it
that's all right I know that I know that
but so so okay fine but first just show
with people believing you that it
produces all these fancy square roots
and things right yeah and examples that
use abstract input you mean like
geometric seen examples abstract
coordinates you can add some like that
yeah yeah I mean let's say in Santa
there we go baby
preferably one which has square roots
and then replace the the D replace the
the the number coordinates with a 180 I
understand yeah right well I did this is
good enough this is a fine result
okay I'm not okay I'm not I'm not
redoing all these examples I'm just
giving you a little indication there
that's beautiful though that that works
okay let's keep going um I think it's
really weird that region centroid is
called region centroid not just centroid
is there a good reason for that
at the Charles question it's officially
off
let's ask Charles that question Oh
Charles here
quiet Charles yes we're asking why is it
called region centroid rather than just
centroid we can't hear you you're
breaking up said again the centroid was
too general why what else could it mean
I'm sorry you're breaking up if you
could call in in some way where you're
not going to break up how bit much
better okay let's keep going here
um oh boy
I think it's going to be tricky to give
this the same treatment we just did
triangle Center
who
you
you
you
this is a big complicated mess
I don't think it's a mess I feel it's
actually reasonable talk shop it is
reasonably structured deal it's big yes
you
I will thought triangle Center and
triangle measurement
wasn't triangle Center first here
obviously the frosted operates rely on
this first need something to operator
all right well we'll leave this them
you
you
okay this is another one of these red
things getting left behind in the 64-bit
front end here
now I think there was a changing table
no but there isn't anymore
oh okay all right let's go to triangle
measurement then
are we going to split this into the ones
that depend on a vertex and those that
don't
maybe not I mean does it have a default
all salts are pretty stupid here I mean
this is pretty you know those defaults
that seem to be less interesting
the defaults are the second vertex yeah
I can see it did that for consistency
with planar angle
you
you
you
what is the semi-perimeter it's not the
limiter apparently it's an important
thing
well we're being a bit lazy here but I
think we don't need to split these
because I'm not sure it's very useful to
split them and all these peas have to be
varices of a triangle look there's an
argument we should try and split these
but let's get more experience with how
the stuff works before we mess around
with that I would like to see us like
encode Euclid or something in in all of
these things ok let's go to find
geometric Conte conjectures since we're
already running out of time um ok this
somewhat horrifying creature I mean this
is what you spent lots of effort on
right is that true or is that not true
is this somehow not as much as inside
you see Gerard the thing jars a
bajillion times more care than this but
this one is more than good sense ok what
else should it point to directrix scene
random instance reduce what else
what about sequence findings no by that
point we tell it and point to image
identify No thank you would never
to identify to make a mathematical
connection but you would vary if they
use some of the secret stuff to find
Kasim a secure connections well fair
enough
all right I'm just
what's that geometric assertion oh yeah
I should look at that's more relevant
than this we should probably set the
right order should it be I mean I think
random instance is kind of like the very
first thing I would say until you
suggested that the Nutri code operates
directly on the scene right but the
scene that it needs the type of scene it
needs to operate on can only really come
through random instance actually okay
going back to line 2 could geometric
scene actually I think technically has
the most lines of code by far
then random instance then find you that
might hold for a it's a geometric scene
with explicit not necessarily okay if
it's not explicit then it will find
explicit instances to get conjectures
for it's not the recommended way for
doing things but it'll work which the
form pad or the match the match pat the
match pet
but the form is typically defined
through a matching then that's okay that
matched the pattern 20 conjectures that
match the pattern pat or tries to find
conjectures but for most a more
important but it's not about Teta
matching it's about is it that anger is
a lie no really but it says here that
they're actual things like this they're
not named forms right well are they
named forms are they are they explicit
pattern matches explicit pattern matches
would literally just find all
conjectures that we can and do a cases
this function is not well cooked in my
opinion no I mean look we should show
what this does okay so if I'm not
mistaken let me just see what this does
here if I give this I get this thing now
I say find geometric conjectures of this
right yeah okay so have we not agreed
that this thing is going to show its
conjectures yes stab you yeah okay so
that'll be the first example here yeah
okay so what if
gave it something which hadn't been
random instance would it also what would
it do then it would use any mean sense
of the hood right under the hood it runs
three random instances and picks out the
list of conjectures that's the longest
since generally if there's a degenerate
scene it will return though conjectures
okay
this function is very weird so are we
going to end up with something that can
do like these two column proof things
that you find in geometry textbooks
right Peter burns is working on that but
it's not gonna be ready until 12:00 1:00
okay and is it consistent in its
operation with this thing it will be
yeah no I mean what does it mean what do
you mean by this statement well I don't
know that the form that it gives the
conjectures in looks like the form that
this is generating yeah in terms of the
language yeah yeah that all that will
happen okay I think what makes it like
which Nate a couple months ago we had a
version where basically this returns to
this embodied connect rows but it's
really not too useful it's hard to make
sense out of it I think it's much nicer
that it's one object and you have two
all together and maybe the name is not
perfect because but it does find the
connectors by the end of the day it
gives you a scene back it would be
something and which scene this geometric
with the actuals but that's not well so
okay so look okay find geometric sent
conjectures
let's see what we really want to say
something like attempts to include the
geometric conjectures in the scene
object exactly finds geologic
conjectures right relevant geometric
conjectures to add to this bus to the
add to the geometric scene object I mean
the first node is basically I know finds
applicable conjectures to add to the
geometric scene object scene the seams
form because it doesn't sign them to it
it transcends n Text M okay finds
applicable trans applicable conjectures
and adds them
how about ads applicable conjectures to
the geometric that's the wrong thing to
say because if I don't like applicable
okay well what's what's the correct
statement how about we go back to what
we had and then at the very end of the
sense comma and adds them to the
geometric scene finds congestion may
hold for the what do you mean by may
hold that's that's not good enough
what do you mean rejection a definition
may hold or conjectures yeah what you
can conjecture that one plus one is
three it still it's a quickie actual
wait a second wait a sec all the things
that this is returning things that are
guaranteed to be true given the generic
scenes both know there are only a
particular instance there just numerical
conjectures they emit astronomical
probability correct but not let's okay
that's why it's fine because we might
miss them and conjecture because it's
fine conjectures that appear to hold for
the
metric scene object scene and adds the
conjectures to the scene specification
no because we earlier used to wrote
there maybe I thought we use seed
specification to more or less fulfilled
to the second argument okay I
conjectures the scene object to hold for
the scene object for the geometric scene
and adds the conjectures to the scene
object someone's asking is this like
equation find equational proof at all no
this is not giving the proof this is
this is finding this is given a
geometric scene it is finding symbolic
conjectures like that that angle is 90
degrees about that scene well okay in
what sense is it the same I mean I
suppose it's the same as find equational
proof in the sense that and which should
be referred to here I agree because find
equational proof is finding lemmas that
are true but it is directed in a
particular direction right I mean this
is find equational proof has an
objective of proving a particular thing
this is just saying given given the
geometric form that I have what might be
true about it adds these conjectures to
the scene object okay so what does this
do does this add all conjectures to all
scene objects or what does it do so if
you're given a list of scenes then it
yeah it takes the inner it runs the know
I understand but what is the output it's
a single geometric scene object just
like above
okay finds conjectures that are pitiful
for all instances scene I of a geometric
scene and gives an return and returns a
combined scene with the conjectures
added that hold for okay finds um keeps
only conjectures that match the pattern
the keeps or it's okay this is pretty
obscure so I mean we should say this in
the geometric scene documentation right
hmm over here we
shows some examples where where we have
added some probably the third even basic
example should add to this some thing
where it has a conclusion so you can see
that that can hang off a geometric scene
we can do that all right I mean this is
a kind of obscure and complicated
function but it is what it is
um I think overall that's a much nicer
thing to having the split into
individual pieces which you must
remember he use to do something this
it's a little bit like data set if
everything in one nice object it does
many things
um yeah I understand I understand I have
a question on our live stream does this
have engineering applications is it
purely academic where first of all
trying to just reproduce Euclid after a
couple of thousand years let's go ahead
I'm saying geometry can synced solvers
are used in yeah right and that's what
this is this is a sophisticated you know
in this case right now 2d geometric
constraint solving system um sort of
problem based geometric sense a method
of storing and providing feedback ask
for some of our examples I don't know
about that um okay I think we should
wrap this meeting I think we've got what
we need here
and I think with folks on the livestream
and actually I am about to go to another
meeting about a completely different
topic there will also be live stream so
look forward to seeing you all there and
are we good here this weekend I think so
I think we can declare victory here and
victory it is I mean well look I'm gonna
be even more convinced when I can see I
think it'd be really cool to go through
the geometric you know statements of
Euclid and be able to put those up in
this form is that plausible is that like
super difficult or what's the deal with
that was as we saw a lot of the Euclid
is constructions not really just a
theorem well ok fair enough but let me
take the things that are the theorems of
Euclid rather than the constructions of
Euclid and can we represent them all
right yeah I think I mean I think there
will be if it's easy to do I think we
should try to do it I think it's a good
way of explaining what we have um
and then just generate a computational
essay that basically is you know you
cleared as a comp you take the theorems
of Euclid as a computational assay so to
speak we can do that I'd really like to
see it yeah okay thank you good stuff
see you later